the Daredevils season 3 trailer dropped
this week it's an official full-length
trailer and I'm gonna give you guys a
leave B baby breakdown if I may
s'alright with number 1 daredevil
holding the cross it's the opening scene
for the trailer this is actually based
on a very popular Marvel Knights cover
of daredevil where Marvel Knights is
kind of like the more adult where Marvel
max is like super violent this is like a
bit tamer next we why the costume looks
different I actually found in the
born-again story which season 3 looks
like it's based on during his recovery
Matt while he's in the coven he goes
into the basement actually cobbles
together a costume and this is the TV
shows version of that after what's
happened with the defenders also I want
to point out Fisk's white suit which is
more comic accurate everyone wanted to
see in that trademark white suit it also
it seems like he's being born again
after he's getting out of prison after
making that plead metaphorically born
yeah yeah and next it seems pretty clear
that kingpin knows that daredevil and
Matt Murdock are the same person you
actually see them at one point talking
to each other in a bar without looking
at each other which is kind of fun and I
in the comic born again Wilson Fisk is
aware that Matt and daredevil are the
same person which is really interesting
so they're really diving to that story
also
I don't know how kingpin actually makes
out of this season if he does know the
identity of Matt Murdock I will have to
see also some other people's faiths are
up in the air but next having someone
trespass daredevil to kind of you know
disgrace his image and whatnot that's
actually from born again as well we
hidden that comic kingpin hires just a
mental patient to run around with them
shockingly I don't think we're gonna see
that in this TV show but also we've seen
bullseye who has been confirmed to be
this character dress up as daredevil in
the Dark Avengers run which is a really
cool comic book run but next bullseye
has been confirmed for the show and in
this and in this series his alias has
been confirmed to be Benjamin Poindexter
which is my favorite from the comics
it's great nay he will never stand out
in the crowd I also want to point out
this scene where he's holding the gun up
is actually based on another daredevil
comic cover which is very cool it was a
pointed out by reddit user gift 95 but
finally this is like the big thing that
I pulled from this trailer the other
daredevil bull's eye we see him at one
point in the New York bulletin which is
the newspaper that Karen page works for
and also famously in the calm
bullseye as killed Karen page that's one
of his big no-no moments in comics so I
don't think she's gonna be making out of
this season but are you guys excited you
can double the daredevil there's no
Elektra maybe this season and you're
getting a lot more Wilson Fisk compared
to season two so what are you thinking
how you feeling and I think what's
really good about going this way with
the using the ultimate version of
daredevil the the doppelganger as
bullseye what's really good is I hope
that they just like use it as a only
explore bullseye as his relationship
with daredevil is I think that that was
really good about what the MCU did with
Winter Soldier like they could have
explored the Winter Soldier more but
really was about the relationship
between Bucky and Steve and I think if
we can just get the relationship between
these characters of daredevil have to
deal with like a non daredevil bizarro
version of him I think that's the thing
that has been most excited no and also
look at that jaw line on that boy right
right that's insane that's crazy this
guy yeah he's probably gonna like
sharpen a little I'll just add real
quick that I'm the one of the reason I'm
excited it's a little bit of a sad
reason but I am I don't know how much
longer these Netflix Marvel shows are
gonna last what the Disney streaming
service coming soon and with that you
know downhill mists of their viewership
since iron fist so I point out you
because you look like an ear and I think
that that means they're gonna leave it
all out there right they're just gonna
like put everything into this season and
just like balls to the wall and bad I'm
really excited for say no the with Luke
Cage and Iron Fist because in the most
recent Netflix series that we've been
able to see they seem to be going more
bite balls-to-the-wall where it's like
Luke Cage they take their character to a
point where it's like if Luke can't get
hurt by anything what actually happens
to a person's character if you can't be
challenged by anyone and that's
interesting iron fist you open up the
the goodie bag of all the history you
can go into and with daredevil it's like
do the story that everyone wants to do
that all of you have wanted to do for so
long so I'm excited for that
also I'm excited to see how pull a
bull's eye pulls like bulls like gets
his hands on this costume because they
could be a cool showdown between
gladiator who made the costume for Matt
and Matt I think there's gonna be a cool
coming it come in at each other yeah
well let us know in the comments below
what you're most excited about from this
trailer and yeah
and well you know tell us how you think
the whole direction of these TV show
should go should the DC or the Disney
streaming service continue them or are
we looking for like an outpoint
thanks everybody